انا اليوم طابخ عدس الي وحبايبي كلهم
النازحين اللي من خان يونس واللي من غزه
واللي من رفع كليتنا تجمعنا في مكان واحد
وصرنا اهل واعز من الاهل بلملم كراتين
الاولاد الصغار بلملم لي كراتين اللي
بلملم خشب كان معي بشتري خشب ب 10 شيكل
معناش بلملم كراتين بنولع نار ونطبخ الطبخ
والله بعمل الاكل هذا بالمجان بعمل اللي
قدرنا عليه ربنا اي طبخه بطبخها اللي
قدرنا ربنا عليها عشان الناس الغلابه اللي
معهم اللي اجوا من من اماكن غزه ماهم حتى
شيكل طلعوا فيه ماشي اجوا لكن ماهم اللي
معهم صغار يعني اضلني اطلع في الصغار انهم
ما ياكلو انا بدي واجبه يعني كعامل هنا
وهذا العمل باخذ اجري عليه يعني من الحمد
لله من الشركه بس انا لما بعمل حاجه لخير
للناس للنازحين انا باخذ دعوه ام النازحين
هي خالتي م جاسر خالتي ام جاسر هي من
القلب الطيب هي دائما تعمل اي شيء بتعمل
لنا اكل طعامنا احنا قبل طعم اولادها
والله احلى شي هي اشوفه بالحرب والله من
يوم ماجيت لهان لليوم تعدنا مثل بناتها
يعني بشوفها بتعاملنا معامله كثير
كويسه حسي اوقات حالك الام والابو نفس
واحد الابو مش موجود انت بدك تسدي في
الشين انت بدك تكوني بدك تكوني قويه مع
انك بتكوني خايفه بتكوني مرعوبه لكن ايش
بدك تكوني قويه قدامهم حتى لو احسب صحتك
على احسب نفسك بس انك ايش تحسسيه هم
بالامان مش شرط هم صح يكونوا اولادك كبار
وهيك بس بتلاقيهم بخافوا ممكن تلاحظي
الخوف في عيونهم هم بدهم يقولوا لك ان
احنا خايفين يا ماما بس الام بتحس الحين
انت مثلا ما يكون مثلا عندك غير كيف ع
ترخه او خمس تخفه للصغار بدك انت تاكلي
ولا هم طبعا الصغار لازم انت تطعميه ايش
فايدتها
ام العبيه هيثم امنا الثانيه يعني لو ايش
ماحكي لك عنها ما بقدرش اوصفها سواء في
حنيتها في ايه في اي شيء يعني اللي في
ايدها مش لها ايش ما بدها لو مين ما طلب
ما بتقولو لا ولا بتقصر فيه احنا هنا خمس
عائلات هنا مع بعض اكلتنا اكلتنا واحده كل
حاجه واحده يعني كل شيء بنعمله مع بعض
نتقسم مع بعض ضحكنا حزنا كليته واحد يعني
يعني اكلنا عيله وامه مسؤوله عن بناتها هي
اللي مثلا بقسم الشغل على بعض طبعا هي
يعني راس الكوم يعني هي المسؤوله عننا كل
بتقسم علينا الشي كيف الام بتكون حنونه
على اولادها وبتخاف عليهم من الهوا وهي
نفس الشي لدرجه اولادي انا كمان هي بتخاف
عليهم اكثر مني
بحسها